with the tampa bay rays this afternoon
it's going to be the left-hander rich
hill coming off of his best start of the
season most pitches thrown
struck out 10 along the way so hoping to
build off of that start here this
afternoon and here is jose altuve and
the cut in the miz he strikes him out
three pitches altuve up and down listen
that was a pitch that he really started
to find in that last start against the
oakland athletics that fastball at the
top of the zone where he can get the
good jump out of it there it is 91 that
ball seemingly rising as it's heading to
home plate and altuve comes up empty
again and we'll see alex bregman and a
swing and a mess
fastball up strikes out bregman tell you
what he has worked the two right-handers
he has faced ironically enough altuve
and bregman he has worked them very well
in that fastball again he's got the good
range on it top of the strike zone good
velocity and bregman as short as he
tries to be he still can't get there
jordan alvarez
and a tapper to the right side for
brandon loud a little underhanded toss
to satsugo
no round to walk a man left couple
strikeouts and now christian javier's
turn doing great this season four starts
he is three and oh in those four starts
and again that opponent batting average
well under 200 and going out there and
racking up strikeouts with 26. randy
arose arena dhing today
and he picks up a strikeout on that
slider getting a rose arena swinging 36
strikeout of the year against rose arena
there's one away here in the first good
slider you can see the late break on
that as a rosarena trying to catch up to
it figure it out pretty well located
miles straw
full count on him now and a cut to miss
he strikes him out got him with a
curveball here's jordan alvarez jordan
grounded out his first time up two balls
and no strikes to yordon
yordon drives one deep right center
field this ball is gone
air jordan
up and flying once again his first home
run since april the 8th and his third on
the season puts the astros on the board
one to nothing a little bit of a smirk
on the face of jordan knowing that that
felt good driving that ball out of the
ballpark to right center field here for
the houston astros get him on the board
get rich hill out of there bring waka in
and here we go with this big swing from
yard on fastball up and he brought the
hands up to meet that baseball and
crushed it out of here estimated 424
feet i got out in a hurry astros leading
the tampa bay rays one to nothing going
for their first sweep ever at tropicana
field lead things off here in the inning
kyle tucker
as tucker delivers a single into center
field and kyle tucker lead off base
runner in the fifth inning has to feel
good for tucker
to find some open space out there i'll
speed pitch that was up from waka and
that'll bring up strong 2-2
and that's driven out to center deep
racing back here meyer on the track
looking up it's off the wall on his way
to third base goes tucker and straw into
second with a double boy that's about
his best bolt straight away center field
straw got all of that one and over kier
meyer's head that's hard to do too it is
was playing in a few steps because of
straw at the plate not expected to hit
for a whole lot of power especially to
straight away center field and tucker he
had to hold up thinking that that ball
might be caught otherwise he would have
scored on that and straw might be
standing at third well jose altuve will
bat the infield stays in on altuve but a
chance here for altuva to drive in a
couple of runs with a base hit which
draws speed on second anything to the
outfield should be two rbis altuve sends
one to the outfield kiermeier backs up
on it he'll have a play tagging at third
and scoring will be tucker straw will
advance to third jose altuve a sacrifice
fly in the astros now lead two to
nothing good job by jose professional
batting going out there and picking up
that rbi get something you can drive the
outfield that pitch was down cutting a
little bit and he was still able to
drive it plenty deep enough to center
field to move everybody up 90 feet well
here's michael brantley brantley facing
waka for the first time as waka came on
and began his outing with alex bregman
michael sends one into shallow center
falling fast and a
base hit for michael brantley just past
the outstretched glove of william thomas
that'll be an rbi single for brantley
it's now a three to nothing astros lead
willie adams just to that second base
side of second base the shortstop and as
bradley fights this off he had a long
way to go almost got there and made a
spectacular play but just out of his
reach it ends up being a base hitting an
rbi for michael brantley austin meadows
two men on the raise mrs sugo at second
base
at first
that's a shot deep in the ride and that
baby's gonna get out of here home run
for austin
boy the rays have been waiting for that
and this game is tied 3-3 home run
number five for austin meadow first home
run given up by javier this year well
the long one and suddenly the raids are
even rbi's 10 11 and 12 for meadows 3-3
astros and razor tied jordan alvarez
stands in against michael walker homer
it is last time
yordon hooks up all down the right field
line that's a fair ball alvarez heading
to second he follows up his home run
with a double to lead off the sixth
inning for the astros good job good job
staying back on the changeup not the
best change-up we've seen from waka but
up out over the plate and jordan
recognizes what's great too is puts his
head down after making contact making
sure he gets into second base tucker and
now he faces the right hand hitting
miles straw
fastball through the middle that's a
base hit in the center field alvarez
heading home he's gonna score throw to
third tucker is safe at third base and
he's taking a breather good to see him
smiling as he gets up must have been an
awkward slide at third but a base hit by
straw on a tough right-hander ryan
thompson big base hit by straw taking
that pitch and shooting it back up the
middle luckily this turf helping that
ball get through this
middle part of the field taking a big
hop off that dirt
kyle tucker forcing the issue running in
front of kiermeier we're never going to
see that slide but it did look awkward
as it tips off the glove of lao allowing
alvarez to score there we go
yeah base play a little bit of an issue
with the landing gear the scary part
about that play is alvarez still had not
scored by the time tucker was going to
third so here's kevin kiermeier meyer a
couple of hits to the left side today
there's a fly ball toward the corner off
the bat of caremeyer that's going to
bound and it's going to be a double that
rebounded out onto the field and
kiermayer hands himself his third hit of
the game two singles and now a double
and tried to start him with a first
pitch curveball you see it right there
of the spike variety and stays up
kiermeier stays on it and he one hops
the uh the foul pole down there oh he's
did a nice job staying on that pitch
hitting it the other way here we go
nothing that brantley could do about it
the rays right back with an immediate
threat against de bruyne runner and
third less than two got to get him in
check swaying in a bounder here comes a
man down the line the throw gets away
kirmar is safe at the plate the throw a
little high in maldonado and it's haste
to maybe try to get a tag had that ball
pop off the mitt
and the raids have tied this game
that right there was the full
understanding of who was on third base
and running on contact that caused this
play there's the check swing guriel's
got a chance to make that play but he's
going to rush the throw because it's
kiermeier running and that ball right in
and out of the glove actually got it
there in time you saw that ball hit
right into the palm
and right out
take him anyway you can get him right
now so hit batter the rays have a base
runner diaz will pinch hit for wendell
ground ball back a third backhanded up
bregman's throw is going to be wild
down there the dugout over to third base
goes meadows and
[Applause]
on the high throw
from bregman and that play duane all
discombobulated from the beginning the
backhand near the line but then right
there it comes loose he grabs it throws
it obviously the grip not very good
it sails
yeah yandy had designs on going to
second and wisely circled back
but boy look at that thing take off
we have a 4-4 ball game in the bottom of
the seventh inning and the wheels are
turning right standing gets the call a
lot in play to try to figure out the
best approach from the range perspective
in this tie game pitch to margot
ground ball right side going to go
through
base hit raise lead meadows scores the
go ahead run turning that hit by pitch
into an opportunity and it's 5-4 tampa
bay on the pinch-hit single location
location location this pitch is down
you want that pitch to be up right there
that's just too easy and that's letting
margot off the hook now okay good just
put in play
hit it to the right side there's nobody
there here comes the run the rays are
not done yet this third out has been
tough to get castro starts to walk off
his lead at second base the 3-2 pitch on
its way the ground ball headed up the
middle deep back of the bag bronzo's
throw is in time and this game is over
and the rays went it ground ball up the
middle by altuve to end this game and
the rays are 5-4 winners